[Music]
have you ever heard of the term binomial
expansion sounds interesting right let's
see what it is wait first let me ask you
a simple question do you know what a
binomial is is x-squared a binomial or
is x + y + Z a binomial no not then what
is a binomial
in simple words a binomial is a
polynomial which is a sum or difference
of only two terms for example say X plus
y squared or x squared plus y cube are
teh binomials yes you're right they are
because they consist of only two terms
let's try and solve this one question
give it a shot
how do we solve this do we multiply 103
with itself course we can but let's try
another method can we write 103 the
whole squared as 100 plus 3 the whole
square will it do surely why not both
these values are equal to each other now
we all know the formula of a plus B the
whole squared right can you tell me what
it is yes it's a squared plus 2 a B plus
B squared hence we can apply this
formula and get the answer of 103 the
whole squared has ten thousand six
hundred and nine this method is much
simpler as compared to multiplying it
the regular way
now consider the same number but this
time let's change the power to three
this is 103 cubed how do we proceed now
yes you're right we do it by using the
formula of a plus beat the whole cubed
this is the formula so we can write 103
as 100 plus 3 substituting 100 in place
of a and 3 in place of B we get the
following answer again easier than
multiplying it the regular way these two
formulae helped us find the answer
easily but what if it was 103 raised to
7 what do we do now it's surely not
feasible to multiply 103 seven times so
what's the solution then do we know any
formula for it we probably don't that's
exactly where binomial theorem comes
into picture
it helps us expand such terms with
higher powers very easily say we have X
plus y raise to 7 or we have X minus y
raise to 9
such expansions can be done very easily
using binomial theorem so what is the
binomial theorem watch our next video to
know more
[Music]
you